let's bring in Tim Cowell Sean Dallas
Morning News columnist around the horn
contributor Tim have you ever been to
Jerry Jones it sounds Dan thank you for
having me I Drive by the Jones mailer
frequently he lives about a mile and a
half from where I do that's not to
suggest it was the same neighborhood oh
okay okay
uh I live it by Kato but one side of
fertile Creek he lives it is whatever
that is I assume it's a beautiful house
there are so many trees you really can't
see it from the street
do you have details on the sleepover the
only details I have are that it may not
have happened so I did I did use the
word May in there you are the Woodward
and Bernstein of sleepovers here yeah I
don't know that that really happened I
don't know that it didn't but I've been
told that it may not have really
happened okay do you know Dave the Jerry
fell in love with Mike McCarthy at first
sight no I believe I believe he fell as
easy as that is to do did I believe he
fell in love before that if you go back
in time here about a week to when Jerry
said he didn't care about the process
being quick he didn't care about other
teams he didn't care who they're
interested in that kind of told us okay
he believes he knows who he is going to
get now we all mistakenly ran off in the
Lincoln Riley Urban Meyer direction when
it's probably as simple as a Mike
McCarthy may interview with other teams
but his agent those the Cowboys are
coming after him and he's not going to
take anything until Dallas talks to him
so I think they had because the
interview two people you know obviously
they interviewed Marvin Lewis hate to
say it that satisfies the Rudy rule
maybe they had some interest I doubt it
yeah because they interviewed Mike
McCarthy and that's in a debt you know
they don't do anything quick around here
we saw how long it such
- just announced that Garrett was gone
and then on Monday morning they had
McCarthy so he may have he may have done
an excellent job at the interview but I
think their mind was made up but they
would have brought it for people but des
and I I know that I carry a lot but in
this case I look at him and say it's the
owner and the GM and usually those are
two different people it's the same
person but two different personalities
it feels like Jerry made the for lack of
a better expression Servet of traits not
sexy we were looking for Urban Meyer
Lincoln Riley but that doesn't mean that
they were the right choices here he
still has control if Mike McCarthy is
there he wouldn't have control if he had
Urban Meyer in there and Lincoln Riley I
think may you know it's better off at
Oklahoma so I I don't know if it's the
right choice I think it's a smart choice
to not go with the shiny object there
what do you think of I said I had a
thumbs up for this and my thumb was at
about 10 o'clock so it's it's leaning a
little bit but it's not straight up but
it's it's a surprisingly conventional
choice for Jerry Jones now why are you
waffling why did you awful on this
because I mean I they clearly didn't
they did it so quickly whatever it was
that caused things to really fall apart
not only with the tea but with Aaron
Rodgers I mean they didn't have time to
explore that so they're basically to say
we don't care we don't care that they
were you want a Super Bowl early and
then never got back to Bud and coached
like Jason Garrett in the NFC
Championship game against Seattle made a
bunch of mistakes there we're just going
to take you based on his resume the
resume is great nine straight playoffs
is great a super boring is great but why
did it go so badly and why did why did
McCarthy feel this could be a good thing
but why did he feel he needed to form
this whole analytics team and tell the
world
hey I'm mr. analytics now he's basically
saying look I know everybody thought I
was a boring you know kick field goals
from the
yard-line putt on fourth and to my own
50-yard line coach I'm gonna change
something compelled him to make that
change and I don't think the Cowboys
really explored everything that went on
with him and Aaron Rodgers he's Tim
Callas on Dallas Morning News columnist
and star of around the horn do you think
they kicked the tires though on Urban
Meyer and Lincoln Riley I think they did
on Lincoln Riley and I think they were
probably told once again Lincoln Riley
is fine where he is and that may have
happened a couple of weeks ago or some
some time ago after after he was done
they may have caught he may have called
them at halftime to the LSU game despite
what you're watching I have stayed I'm
gonna endure this see I thought you know
Lincoln Riley needed to have an extra
day before this decision was made so he
could have called a press conference to
say he's taking his name out of the
running for the Cowboys so then it looks
better this was just like oh they just
breezed right by your exit off the
highway I started back to when when
Jerry Jun said Jason Garrett is going to
be coaching in the NFL next year he
didn't say with the Cowboys do you think
Jason Garrett is coaching in the NFL
next year Tim that's your Jerry jugs I
got to say let me just do this well he's
not going to get what's left Cleveland
and Carolina
well the Giants but I don't think no I
don't think he will be I think it'll
take a year off I think he'll be like
not to say he has a save record but sit
out a year like McCarthy and then when
this happens next year there's six new
openings two of those teams will be
interested in you'll get one of those
jobs I'd be surprised if these teams
that have already conducted three or
four interviews each are going to jump
in on Jason although you know the rumor
was back in whatever November that the
Giants rich did so I suppose and he
could still get to the running data but
I assume everybody here kind of assumes
perhaps wrongly that
rulers getting it up in that job Jim
it's great to talk to you are you one
around the horn today I am there that
I'm looking forward to you know if I win
twice a month this year I'll get to 500
so that's a real push but you'll never
you'll never catch woody right not
without something awful happening that I
won't even get into he would have to
stop making appearances that's what
that's what without that we could just
say you'd have to find another show no I
am in school as we like to say the
sports rider biz is that number two spot
is waiting solid them is woody page the
Tom Brady of around the horn bad I guess
he is but what if that means I'm
Belichick no no no your quarterbacks
you're not you can be hard
what about so I'm your Favre far yeah
I'll be far I'll live I could live with
that
yeah I can be there before keep your
head up I can deal with it yeah it's now
there you've got to depress me realize I
should witness fifteen shows a year for
seven years and if woody wins it he
shows at all I still haven't caught it
why don't you call you shot that you're
gonna win tonight alright I think I
think I got this one I cuz I got a good
face time playing so I think it's going
out Boyd right now you can't see it I'm
pointing right now alright well and God
God's speed and then I wish you luck and
we'll be praying for you thank you
that's Tim Couch on called his shot for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]